Picture this. You've just spent a small fortune on this luxury houseboat vacation.
Oh man, I can already see where this is going.
Right. So you arrive at this beautiful, pristine lake. But by day three, you are just utterly exhausted.
Yeah, you're practically doing manual labor.
Exactly. You're spending your mornings hauling heavy groceries down these steep, slippery dirt banks. You're dragging luggage across docks.
It's like the opposite of a vacation.
It really is. Every evening you're wrestling with heavy anchors just to secure the boat. And then on top of all that, you're cooking every single meal yourself.
Yeah.
You paid for a premium getaway, but somehow you are doing intense physical labor on your own vacation. And I mean, why does this happen?
Well, it happens because the company that sold you that vacation didn't really know how to map the invisible.
Which perfectly brings us to our mission for this deep dive today. We are decoding the invisible architecture of the services you interact with like every single day.
It's honestly one of the most common and frankly most expensive blind spots in modern business.
For sure. Because we try to manage experiences and services using the exact same tools that we use to manage physical, tangible objects.
And that just completely breaks down. It doesn't work.
So today we're looking at the fundamental physics of how services operate. We'll look at how massive corporations draw literal maps to manipulate your experience without you even realizing
it.
Yeah. And finally, how those exact same maps are being used right now to teach artificial intelligence how to interact with human beings.
It's fascinating. And to do this, we're pulling insights from this really great stack of research spanning the last 40 years. We've got foundational theories from a 1982 paper by G. Lynn Shostak.
Yeah, that's a classic.
Then a 2008 practical guide by Bittner, Ostrom, and Morgan. And all the way up to a cutting-edge case study from 2023 by Magyari and Sekimandi on machine learning.
The evolution here is just wild. I mean, we're going to trace a direct line from the economics of like a corner shoeshine stand all the way to complex neural networks in modern hospitals.
It's a huge journey. And for you listening, whether you're a manager trying to fix a broken customer experience or you just want to know why your favorite coffee shop operates the way it does.
Yeah, understanding this concept of service blueprinting is, well, it's the ultimate shortcut to seeing the matrix of the modern economy.
OK, let's unpack this. We have to start with the physics of invisible things.
Right. Because to map a service, we first have to accept that a service fundamentally disobeys the laws of physics that govern physical products.
Which is just laid out back in the early 80s.
Exactly. And the distinction really boils down to dimensions. So a physical product like a smartphone or a toaster, it exists in both time and space.
You can hold it. You can weigh it.
Right. You can possess it. But a service exists exclusively in time. It cannot be possessed. It can only be rendered and experienced.
Because it only exists in time. It's inherently fleeting.
Right.
I mean, you can't put a haircut on a shelf and just save it for later.
That is the crucial constraint. So think of a service as being kind of like electricity. It exists in two completely different states.
Like potential and kinetic energy.
Exactly. Let's use your barber example. When that trained barber is just sitting in an empty shop reading a magazine, they represent potential energy. They possess this stored capability to cut hair, but nothing is actually happening. The
actual haircut, the service itself, is kinetic energy.
Got it. So it only exists while it is in motion, while the shears are moving and the hair is falling.
Right. But in the real world, most of the things we buy aren't purely one or the other. You know, we rarely buy just pure potential energy or pure kinetic energy.
That brings us to what Shostak called the molecular model, right?
Yeah. Market entities are almost always these combinations of products and services linked together like atoms in a molecule.
So like table salt would be a pure product atom.
Exactly. There's virtually no service attached to a box of salt. But look at a car. A car is a massive product atom, but it's fundamentally bound to the service atom of transportation.
And if you swing to the far other end of the spectrum.
Then you have something like an amusement park. An amusement park is almost entirely a kinetic service with maybe like a few minor product atoms thrown in.
Like a plastic souvenir cup or a hot dog or whatever.
Yeah, exactly. I
love looking at it as a chemistry set for businesses. Because if you alter just one atom in that molecule, you fundamentally change the reality of what you're selling.
Oh, for sure.
Like if you take the transportation service atom away from that car, it just ceases to be a vehicle. It becomes like a museum piece, a sculpture.
And because those kinetic atoms, the service parts, are invisible and intangible, they desperately rely on physical proxies to make them feel real to the consumer.
Which is what Shostak calls evidence.
Right. And there are two kinds. So peripheral evidence is something like an airline ticket or a receipt. The ticket isn't the flight itself, right?
No, it just confirms that the service exists.
Exactly. But then there's essential evidence. Essential evidence actually facilitates the service and it completely dictates your psychological trust in it.
So the airplane itself would be essential evidence.
The airplane, the cleanliness of the tray table, the pilot's uniform. I mean, think about it. You wouldn't trust a surgeon who walks into the operating room wearing muddy boots and a torn T-shirt.
Definitely not.
Even if their kinetic skill, their actual surgical ability is world class, the essential evidence fails. The tangible evidence heavily manipulates how we perceive that intangible experience.
OK, let me push back on this a little bit, though. If a service is kinetic and it's always in motion, like that haircut or that surgery, how can a business possibly standardize it without just stripping away the humanity?
That's the big challenge.
Right. Because you could put a toaster on an assembly line and guarantee every toaster is identical. But you can't mass produce a haircut. Humans are messy, unpredictable variables.
That unpredictability is exactly why the earliest service models introduced this concept of deviation tolerances.
Deviation tolerances.
Yeah. So every service has an engineered ideal blueprint, but it also has a built-in tolerance for deviation. Let's look at a simple street corner shoeshine. The standard engineered blueprint for that shoeshine might dictate that the process should take
exactly two minutes now as a consumer your tolerance might stretch up to five minutes
so if i'm sitting there for four minutes i'm still perfectly happy
right the kinetic energy feels fine to you but beyond five minutes your perceived quality of the service plummets you start checking your watch
so the business has a nice comfortable three minute buffer to play with where the customer is still happy right
Well, see, that is the trap most businesses fall into.
Wait, really?
Yeah. They think the buffer belongs to the customer. But remember, for the business, the raw material of a service is time. Oh, wow. At two minutes, the shoeshine operator makes, let's say, a 20-cent profit margin. But if the shine drags on to four
minutes, the cost of that extra labor and time eats the margin entirely.
So the profit drops to zero.
Exactly. The customer thinks everything is completely fine at four minutes. But internally, the business is literally losing money on every single shoe they shine.
Wow. So the blueprint isn't just about making sure the customer smiles. It's this highly sensitive mathematical balance between the customer's patience and the provider's internal profitability.
Yes. The customer's tolerance and the profit tolerance are totally different metrics.
And once businesses started to realize that these invisible kinetic events had such strict, unforgiving profit margins, I imagine they realized they couldn't just wing it anymore.
No, they needed a literal map to track this energy.
Which moves us from the theoretical physics of the 80s into the practical tools of the 2000s. Yeah. We're talking about the evolution into the modern service blueprint.
Right. So the 2008 paper, the modern blueprint takes all of that kinetic energy and standardizes it across five core components.
Break those down for us.
Sure. You map out the customer actions, the onstage or visible employee actions, the backstage or invisible employee actions, the support processes, and finally, that physical evidence we talked about earlier.
I want to focus on how this is actually drawn because the structure of it is so fascinating. It relies heavily on these rigid boundaries. They call lines.
The lines are the secret sauce, really. Imagine drawing a map of a coffee shop on a whiteboard. At the top, you have the line of interaction.
That's where the customer directly touches the business, right? Like ordering at the register.
Exactly. And just below that is the most crucial boundary, which is the line of visibility.
Okay, so everything above that line is seen by the customer.
Yeah, the barista steaming the milk, the pastry display, the music playing. Everything below it is completely invisible to them.
And below that?
Below that, you have the line of internal interaction. That separates the frontline staff from back-end support, like the person in the back room roasting the coffee beans or the payroll software.
It basically operates entirely like a theater production.
Yes, that's a perfect analogy.
The customer is the audience and they only see the actors on stage. But those actors look like fools if the stagehands backstage aren't pulling the ropes.
Right. And none of them can function without the lighting grid and the power supply, which are the support processes deep in the basement.
And seeing those lines on a piece of paper can radically alter how a company operates. Let's look at that yellow transportation example from the paper.
Oh, that's such a good case study. They were a massive trucking and logistics company. Back in 1997, they were literally scraping the bottom of Fortune's least admired companies list. Ouch.
So they were really struggling.
Very much so. So they sat down and mapped out their core delivery service using a blueprint.
What did the map show them that they couldn't already see? I mean, they're a trucking company.
It showed them their true face. The executives probably assumed their brand was their corporate logo or their expensive sales team. But when they drew the line of interaction, they
realized who was actually crossing it.
Exactly. They realized the only people constantly crossing that line were their unionized Teamster truck drivers. The driver backing the rig into the loading dock, handing over the clipboard, making small talk with the warehouse manager. That driver was the primary onstage
actor.
So the executives were pouring money into things below the line of visibility when the entire customer experience was happening above the line in the cab of an 18-wheeler.
The blueprint made it undeniably clear. So Yellow Transportation pivoted hard. They shifted their entire operational strategy to support those drivers.
They upgraded the technology in the cabs, right? Yep,
revamped their training to focus on customer interaction and treated the drivers as the core brand ambassadors. That shift, driven entirely by seeing that line of visibility, helped take them from worst to first in their industry.
That's incredible. But what happens if you don't have a backstage at all?
What do you mean?
Well, the research brings up Marie Stopes International, which provides reproductive health clinics in developing countries. Their challenge was completely different because their clinics operate with almost 100% on-stage action.
Oh, right. Yeah, that is an incredibly difficult model to manage because in those rural clinics, the customer sees absolutely everything.
There's no curtain to hide behind.
Exactly. The entire process from walking in to the consultation to the procedure happens above the line of visibility.
So how do you blueprint an experience when you can't hide the messy support processes?
You have to tie everything to the exact second it is needed on stage. They modified their blueprint to link soft skills with hard physical evidence.
Soft skills like what?
Like the specific moments a nurse needs to show empathy or ask a sensitive question. And they linked those to physical things like the sterility of the equipment or handing over a specific pamphlet.
Wow, so the blueprint dictated exactly what needed to be in the room and what needed to be said.
Moment by agonizing moment. It leaves zero room for negative deviation.
Okay, so a map shows you where the employees are and what they need. But does it show you what the customer is actually feeling?
It can, yeah.
Because earlier we talked about that houseboat vacation. If a company genuinely thinks they're selling a premium luxury experience, but it's actually miserable, does a piece of paper catch that?
It catches it perfectly if you map the customer's actions chronologically, which is exactly what Aramark did with those Lake Powell houseboat rentals.
Oh, so they mapped out the pain.
Right. Aramark was bleeding repeat business. People would come once and just never return. They couldn't figure out why until they drew the blueprint of the actual customer journey day by day, hour by hour.
And that's where they saw the exhaustion.
The map laid it bare. The customers were performing dozens of difficult taxing actions above the line of visibility.
Hauling gear, piloting a massive vessel, cooking, cleaning.
The blueprint visualized the customer's physical pain.
They drew a map of exhaustion, and then they engineered it out of existence.
Exactly. They moved the pain below the line of visibility. Aramark invented a whole new suite of concierge services.
They offered to load the groceries for the guests.
They offered piloting services to park the boats. They even offered executive chefs. By redesigning the blueprint to move all that heavy lifting backstage, they cut customer complaints by 50%.
and massively boosted their repeat business. It's brilliant. They just shifted the weight across the line. But here's the thing. All these examples, the shoeshine, the truck drivers, the houseboat concierges, they all rely on human employees doing the
heavy lifting. What happens to the blueprint when the employee executing those backstage processes isn't a human being at all, but like a machine learning algorithm?
Oh, now we arrive at the absolute frontier of this field. This is the 2023 case study where researchers looked at designing human-centric AI.
Specifically, they were trying to build an AI digital scribe for orthopedic doctors.
Right, which is a desperate need right now. The current medical system essentially forces doctors to be data entry clerks.
Yeah, taking electronic notes during a consultation forces the doctor to constantly multitask. They're staring at a glowing screen, typing furiously instead of actually looking at the patient.
It completely destroys the human empathy and trust they're trying to establish in the room. It is a massive kinetic failure.
So the proposed solution was an AI assistant that just listens quietly to the consultation.
Exactly. They utilized automated speech recognition, or ASR, to transcribe the audio of the conversation in real time. Then they used natural language processing NLP to analyze that massive block of text,
categorize it, and automatically fill out the patient's standardized medical template.
Which in this field is called an anamnesis. Right. But building an AI like that is incredibly complex. I mean, you can't just tell an algorithm to, quote unquote, be a doctor. No, not at all. To figure out what the AI actually needed to output, the team used the Moscow method to prioritize the
features.
It is a phenomenal triage tool for development. Moscow stands for must-haves, should-haves, could-haves, and won't-haves.
Okay, so they sat down with the clinicians and rigorously categorized every single data point.
Yeah. What must the AI capture absolutely perfectly? What should it capture, if possible? And what will we explicitly tell the AI to ignore?
It strips away all the nice-to-haves so the engineers know the exact baseline required for the doctor to function.
Exactly. But even with clear priorities, the case study reveals the severe communication breakdown between the people building the AI and the people designing the interface.
A classic clash of disciplines.
Very much so. You have machine learning engineers, the people writing the core algorithms, and they tend to view the human user as a black box.
Right. To an engineer, the doctor is just a source of audio inputs, and the screen is just an output for text.
On the other side, you have the user experience designers. They deeply understand the doctor's workflow and human needs, but they don't fully grasp the technical limitations or the latency of the data processing.
They were essentially speaking two different languages while trying to build the same house.
So they used the service blueprint as a translation device.
Oh, that's clever.
Yeah. They mapped the entire consultation. Above the line of visibility in the doctor's physical world, the UX designer mapped the human actions.
Like the doctor pressing a record button, speaking with the patient, examining a knee, reviewing text on a tablet.
Right. And below the line of visibility, deep in the infrastructure, they mapped the exact moments the speech recognition generated transcripts, and the NLP classified the data.
So the blueprint takes this abstract code and gives it a physical location in time and space.
It was a breakthrough. Suddenly, the engineers aren't just looking at random data queries. They're looking at a chronological map of a doctor's actual day.
It completely reframed the AI. It was no longer just a piece of standalone code. The blueprint proved it was a shared organizational resource.
Exactly. The human and the system were actively co-creating the medical record together.
I do have a major question about this, though, because doctors are notoriously proud and highly protective of their individual note-taking styles. It's a specialized skill they've honed for years.
Oh, absolutely.
So if we automate this process and have a machine categorize their thoughts, aren't we stripping away the nuance of medicine? Won't doctors absolutely rebel against a computer telling them what the official record should say?
That is a highly valid concern, and it's something the researchers confronted head on. During the user research phase, the doctors expressed extreme anxiety about losing control over the quality and accuracy of their own notes.
Yeah, they feared the AI would hallucinate or miss critical context.
So how did drawing a blueprint resolve a fundamental fear of artificial intelligence?
How did they do it?
By allowing the team to visually design a mixed initiative model. Because they could see the line of internal interaction on the map, they made a crucial design choice.
Which was?
The AI does not finalize the notes. It only suggests them.
Oh, I see.
The UX designer ensured that the interface would present the AI's work as pre-filled fields in a draft state. The doctor retains absolute, final control to accept, reject, or rewrite those fields and to add their own free text.
So the blueprint positioned the machine as a hyper-competent assistant below the line rather than a replacement above the line.
Exactly. It keeps the human firmly in the driver's seat.
It's the ultimate collaboration. The AI does all the heavy, exhausting cognitive labor backstage below the line of visibility.
Which frees up the doctor to be fully present, making eye contact and building trust on stage with the patient.
And that really brings the concept of the blueprint full circle, doesn't it?
Yeah.
It is still just managing potential and kinetic energy, even when the energy is digital.
Completely.
Well, we have covered a massive amount of ground today. We started with the realization that a service isn't a thing. It's a fleeting moment in time that has to be mathematically balanced between customer tolerance and company profit.
Yep, the shoeshine.
Then we saw how drawing a literal map could save a failing trucking company by revealing its true face or rescue a luxury vacation brand by visualizing the invisible labor they were forcing on their guests.
The power of the line of visibility.
And finally, we've explored how this exact same mapping technique is the bridge that allows cold calculating machine learning to assist rather than replace humans in the high stakes environment of a hospital.
It's an amazing evolution.
So what does this all mean for you listening? Well, I challenge you to look closely at the services you interact with this week. It could be grabbing a coffee, navigating a banking app on your phone, or checking into a hotel.
Yeah, look past the obvious.
Try to spot that invisible line of visibility. Ask yourself, what hidden mechanisms are grinding away backstage right now to make this seamless onstage moment possible?
And if we take that thought experiment a step further into the future, here is something to ponder.
Okay, let's
hear it. As AI models become exponentially more powerful, we are going to be able to blueprint services with flawless precision. Algorithms will predict our needs before we speak, perfectly categorize our preferences, and manage every backstage process without a
single dropped ball. So... If AI truly masters the perfect frictionless service blueprint, will the messy, unpredictable, kinetic nature of human to human interaction eventually become a rare luxury? Oh, wow.
Bag aids from now. Will human error actually be the new premium experience?
A
perfectly flawed experience because a human being was actually there to make the mistake.
I love that. It really brings us right back to the beginning. When you buy a physical product, you're holding glass and metal. But when you buy a service, you're holding time. Yeah. And as it turns out, designing time might be the most powerful engineering trick we have ever invented. Thank you for joining us on
this deep dive. Keep questioning the invisible architecture all around you.